good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock we're in the Lancashire Village
of Saint Michael's on wire this morning
police are expected to complete the
process of formally identifying a body
discovered around a mile from where
Nicola bully disappeared her partner
Paul anselors told Sky News he has no
words right now just agony
she was last seen more than three weeks
ago walking her dog along the river wire
after dropping her daughter's age six
and nine at school it's Monday the 12th
at 20th give me of February the
discovery will raise more questions for
Lancashire police and inspectors report
last year found the force needs to
improve the way it investigates crime
two Walkers spotted a body washed up in
reeds on the bank of the river wire
yesterday morning
police closed off roads and deployed
specialist divers while helicopters and
drones were seen overhead
also this morning 11 000 ambulance
drivers paramedics and emergency care
workers walk out in England and Wales
the United States warns China of serious
consequences if Beijing sends weapons
and ammunition to help Russia's war in
Ukraine
a former brexit Minister warns that up
to a hundred conservative MPS could vote
against Rishi sunak's brexit deal on
Northern Ireland we'll hear from the
dup's Sammy Wilson on this program
[Music]
good morning from Saint Michaels on why
the family of Nicola bully are waiting
this morning for police to formally
identify a body discovered yesterday
around a mile from where she disappeared
her partner Paul ancillus tolsga news he
has no words right now just agony
the 44 year old mum of two was last seen
more than three weeks ago prompting a
police search of the river wire with
specialist diving teams equipped with
sonar Lancashire police faces growing
questions over its investigation and
it's emerged that an inspector's report
last year found the force needed to
improve the way it investigates crime
the river wire has been the focus of the
search operation since Ms bully went
missing on the 27th of January yesterday
afternoon police confirmed a body had
been recovered from the water about a
mile from where she was last seen
in a statement Lancashire police said we
were called today at 11 36 a.m to
reports of a body in the river wire
close to royalcliffe Road an underwater
search team and specialist officers have
subsequently attended the scene entered
the water and have sadly recovered a
body no formal identification has yet
been carried out so we are unable to say
whether this is Nicola bully at this
time
procedures to identify the body are
ongoing we are currently treating the
death as unexplained Nicholas family
have been informed of developments and
our thoughts are with them at this most
difficult of times we ask that their
privacy is respected into covered story
throughout with us now when will we know
whether it's Nicola that is the big
question police will have yesterday
throughout the day since they recovered
that body in the river wire carried out
procedures to identify who it is they
retrieve from the river wire
um Nicholas family were kept up to date
throughout the day yesterday and last
night and I think Lancashire police will
want to work quickly on this given the
nation's eyes have been on this story
over the last three weeks and of course
for some closure for the family who've
had an immense roller coaster over the
last three weeks when I spoke spoke to
Nicholas partner Paul last night the
words from him were the family are in
absolute agony they are heartbroken and
they just had no more words they said he
said to me that they were all together
last night and so they need to remain
strong I think that word agony I mean
was it Agony waiting to find out whether
it was Nicola that was retrieved from
the water or did they know by then were
they informed by police that it
potentially was Nicola who was retrieved
from the river wire about a mile down
from where she last went missing if we
just recap quickly K what happened
yesterday I think it's important for
everyone at home to know that the police
helicopter arrived around 10 past one
yesterday after reports from two dog
walkers at 11 36 that there was a body
in the river wire there was a huge
police operation here probably the
largest we've seen for about a week or
so the there were drones used they were
underwater divers they were very senior
levels of police officers at the scene
and I think the most striking point for
me is when I saw the senior
investigating officer Rebecca Smith who
was looking into the investigation of
the missing person Nicola bully that was
a really telling sign yesterday I think
but the police presence was huge there
was a cordon main roads cordoned off as
well public footpaths cordoned off and I
think what we saw yesterday was a
significant development from Lancashire
police retrieving a body from the river
yeah six months ago Lancashire police
were told that they needed to improve
how they investigated crime
just over three weeks ago a woman
disappeared a mum of two just over here
more than three weeks later her body's
been far less than a mile away yeah
potentially that is
um what has happened I think there has
been a huge Spotlight on Lancashire
police over the last three weeks for a
whole host of reasons
um it's down to the fact that you know
why wasn't the area cordoned up straight
away where Nicola Bolly where Nicola
bully was found why wasn't
um there you know a senior investigating
officer implemented straight away it
took them a good few days in order for
Rebecca Smith to be identified as the
sio but also the senior investigator
officer but also why is it that
Lancashire police felt that they needed
to reveal very personal very private
details about Nicola bully saying that
she had specific vulnerabilities those
being suffering with with issues of
alcohol saying that she was struggling
with the menopause saying that police
had visited her home 17 days before she
went missing due to concerns of welfare
and this is a case that has gone to the
very top of government Rishi sunak
wading in saying that he had concerns
about why Lancashire police felt they
needed to introduce those details I
think then it all harks back to the fact
that the independent office for police
conduct will be reviewing this
Lancashire police have launched their
own internal review the information
commissioner asking questions as well
and swella bravman the Home Secretary
has had to be kept up to date with
Lancashire police about the
investigation and demand answers as to
why they have to release that
information the police have always said
that as far as they were concerned she
was in the river if that is the case why
did they really release that information
if it wasn't for reputation management
well look I think there was um you know
a lot of pressure on police early doors
to give a sense of what's gone on here
because there was no obvious answer
there were no clues there was no
evidence but in um in press conferences
earlier on
um it was a superintendent who was
giving us information a uniformed
officer and she told us that they
believed their working hypothesis is
that Nicola bully fell into the river
that was their words those words changed
over a few different press conferences
they said she accidentally slipped or
she fell or she ended up entered the
water ended up in the water so there was
an absolute Clarity on what they truly
believed on what happened to Nicola
bully all the while they have said they
kept an open mind but very quickly they
came out the blocks and said that that's
what they believe happened the big
question mark though is K is there is a
10 minute window a 10 minute window
unaccounted for in terms of Nicola's
movements they've managed to gather CCTV
Witnesses and things like that around
the area a very rural area you know it's
into a forest onto very Open Fields as
well and they're just trying to identify
exactly what has happened in that 10
minute window that's the huge question
mark and Lancashire police despite the
fact that they've recovered this body
will still be trying to figure that out
okay for now thanks very much indeed
well let's have a look at how the
morning's papers have reported this
story should we the male leads with the
news that a body has been found by
police searching for Nicola bully less
than a mile from where she vanished the
location of the body close to where the
mum of two was last seen is also the
main story in the express
while the mirror say the news was the
family's worst fear
the times as divers were deployed to an
outcrop of trees and reeds in the river
wire after two Walkers called the police
the telegraph also leaves on the story
featuring a picture of Nicola on the
front page
an image of Nicola is on the front of
the Guardian but their main story
focuses on a warning of shattered
healthcare workers
and to that end the NHS will be hit by a
further round of strikes today with
thousands of ambulance workers walking
out in England and Wales in their
dispute overpay and Staffing joining us
now our correspondent Fraser board hi
Fraser um tell us where you are this
morning
villain service many of their members on
strike today seven of the ten ambulance
trusts across England are being affected
today and ambulance services in Wales as
well eleven thousand members of the GMB
Union on strike members of unite Union
also on strike today their strike will
continue in Wales the unite members will
continue their striking Wells tomorrow
and on Wednesday as well the union
leaders are saying that the governments
are being tenured when it comes to
listening to their Grievances and to
their pay claims the government say that
these strikes are in nobody's best
interests and that they encourage the
unions to seek sense and to get back
around the negotiating table and come to
an agreed settlement and also to to
avoid further strike action the NHS
advice Remains the Same as in previous
strikes down 999 only in
life-threatening emergencies anything
else contact 111 or your local GP or
your local pharmacist and also today
we're hearing we're expecting to hear
the results of industrial ballot action
from the junior doctors in the BMA 45
000 of them have voted if it's a yes
they'll go on strike for three days
sometime in the near future
thank you Fraser meantime the U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken has
warned China there will be consequences
if it provides material support to
Russia and its invasion of Ukraine our
defense and security editor Deborah
Haynes is with us now in Keith good
morning Deborah did he go any further
than that
good morning well the very fact that he
said this publicly is pretty significant
in itself it's once again an example of
the U.S releasing declassifying
intelligence
um in order to give a warning you'll
remember in the run-up to the full-scale
invasion of Ukraine by Russia almost a
year ago to this day the U.S and the UK
spoke out using Declassified
intelligence to warn that Russia was
about to launch this war others didn't
believe that it would happen but they
were right and once again what you're
seeing from the U.S is them speaking
that they have information that China is
thinking about giving weapons to Russia
to help in its War that's that's hugely
important it's something that Beijing
has chosen not to do over the past 12
months despite according to U.S
intelligence the Russians going to the
Chinese to ask for weapons and for
ammunition why is it significant China
another superpower a huge military if
they were to start supplying arms to
Russia it would significantly help the
Russian forces that have been using huge
amounts of ammunition here in this war
there have been warnings for both sides
that stockpiles are running low and so
any country in particular China stepping
in to help Russia would of course be of
serious concern to the west and again
once more further create this dividing
line really cold war style between
Western allies and China Russia and
those others that have been supporting
this war
okay for no
um thank you uh coming up later on on
the program I'm going to be speaking
with John Bolton who is a former State
advisor to Donald Trump so watch out for
more on that we'll also hear what the
dup's Sammy Wilson thinks of a potential
agreement with the EU over Northern
Ireland's post-breactic trading
Arrangements
and at half past the hour we'll be
talking to it's a piece of far heavy
formative Constable of the greater
Manchester police about the
investigation Into The Disappearance of
Nicola bully
and this week marks the one year
anniversary of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine as I said joined by John Bolton
North Korea has fired two ballistic
missiles off its East Coast as it warned
of using the Pacific as our firing range
the missiles which Pyongyang claim can
be armed with a nuclear weapon fell into
the sea outside Japan's exclusive
economic zone Kim yo Jong the sister of
the North Korean leader the ACT says the
action was in response to annual South
Korea U.S military drills
let's bring in our Asia correspondent
Helen and Smith hello to you Helen arms
tell us more about this please good
morning
uh good morning Kay yeah we heard this
morning that North Korea had fired two
ballistic missiles off its East Coast
they landed in the sea just off the west
coast of Japan and it comes two days
after uh North Korea launched an
intercontinental ballistic missile on
Saturday now that's the sort of missile
that theoretically could hit targets
directly on the other side of the world
so a really really serious uh missile
launch and in response to Saturday's
launch the US undertook joint military
drills with South Korea and separately
with Japan as well and it is that type
of response that type of joint drills
between the U.S and South Korea and
Japan that the North Koreans find deeply
deeply provocative and that explains the
the missile launches today but it it's
part of what we've been seeing is a more
repetitive pattern really in terms of
the increased tensions on the Korean
Peninsula last year more missiles were
launched by North Korea in the year of
2022 than at any time in any year since
the current leader Kim Jong-un came to
power there and this sort of response uh
either side is something that we've been
seeing more regularly the real concern
uh certainly for South Korea for Japan
and for the US and its allies is if and
when uh North Korea moves forward to
test another nuclear weapon it hasn't
done that for five or six years and and
if and when that happens uh that will be
seen as a real escalation and that is
something that many powers in the region
are very worried about
okay hold on thank you looking at some
of today's other headlines for you now
on the breakfast show here on Sky more
than 30 people have died following
floods and landslides in Two Cities
north of Sao Paulo searches say that a
seven-year-old girl was among those that
died weather forecasts suggest heavy
rains will continue along San Paulo's
Coast
the body of the footballer Christian
atsu who died when an earthquake struck
turkey two weeks ago has been flown back
to his native Ghana the 31 year old was
found dead in the ruins of a hotel in
southern turkey he previously played for
Premier League clubs Newcastle Everton
and Chelsea
an Australian man has died after being
attacked by a shark in waters of New
Caledonia in the French Pacific the 59
year old man was swimming near a barge
in the capital nueme when the shark
attacked emergency crews tried to save
the man who died after suffering bite
wounds to his leg and both arms
a report has found that families of
black people who died following contact
with the police are unable to get
accountability from A system that says
it's not fit the purpose joining us now
is our correspondent Ashna harina good
morning Ashna
good morning Kay I'm standing outside
the home office the body which funds the
independent office for police conduct
the police Watchdog which stands accused
of failing families according to charity
according to a charity called inquest
the racial disparity between black
people and those who are wise is bigger
than previously thought black people are
seven times more likely to die following
police restraint compared to those who
are wise there are also some other Stark
statistics in this report published
today but essentially the blame is being
put at the foot of the door of the iopc
a body which as I say is meant to
investigate such instance but this body
this charity found that the system is
failing black families officers aren't
being held accountable for instance
involving race and no death of a black
person has led to a any officers being
or facing any disciplinary action in
incidents involving race the iopc in
response to this has said in a statement
evidence of disproportionality in the
use of police Powers has long been a
concern which impacts on the confidence
in policing particularly in black Asian
and minority ethnic communities we
remain committed they say to working
with inquest the charity that conducted
this report and others to reduce deaths
in custody and end the
disproportionality that people of color
face in policing The Wider criminal
justice system and society as a whole
the home office says that nobody's race
should determine how much force is used
on them when they're being restrained
but if you ask this charity for certain
communities it is happening more than
others
[Music]
thank you well there's growing
speculation that the government could
announce a deal with the EU in the
coming days over post-brexit trading
Arrangements in Northern Ireland the dup
has refused to allow Northern Ireland's
devolved institutions to form a
government because they object to checks
on trade with other parts of the UK
which were agreed by the former prime
minister Boris Johnson to ensure an open
border on the island of Ireland Sammy
Wilson the upmp for East antrimp is with
us now hello Tim Mr Wilson thanks for
joining us
um this morning
um after the prime minister's visit to
Northern Ireland the dup leader your
boss Jeffrey Donaldson saying that
Richard faced I'm quoting a big moment
to agree the right deal for Northern
Ireland what is the right deal for
Northern Ireland
great deal for Northern Ireland is first
of all to ensure that Northern Ireland
is treated in this exact same way as the
rest of the United Kingdom in other
words that the laws which apply in
Northern Ireland under UK laws not EU
laws we've now left the EU that the
people in Northern Ireland have got the
ability where the issues are devolved to
decide what laws that we have applied
here not Brussels and as a result of
that then all of the other issues about
barriers to trade and checks on Goods
would no longer be necessary
um and that's really is the the
objective that the Prime Minister has to
achieve when he uh negotiates with the
EU so far what we've had is some
tinkering with the protocol but the
fundamental issue of the protocol is
that Northern Ireland is now separated
from the rest of the United Kingdom
that's impacted on the Union in fact the
active Union has had to be changed as a
result of that and we are we find
ourselves economically disadvantaged
because Goods can't be brought in from
GB without going through a border
checkpoint and being checked or else
there's huge bureaucratic barriers put
in the way of GB firms training in
Northern Ireland those are the issues
that need to be addressed
um I think most people would agree that
that oven ready deal was probably Half
Baked and something does have to be done
but what did eup do if the UK and the EU
reach an agreement without your
involvement
well we will then continue to refuse to
implement it and that means that we
cannot participate in the Storm at
assembly because essentially if a dealer
is agreed which still keeps us within
the EU single Market
as ministers in the Northern Ireland
assembly we would be required by law to
implement that deal and we're not going
to do that because we believe that such
an arrangement is designed to take us
out of the United Kingdom and indeed
would take us out of the United Kingdom
because increasingly we would have to
agree EU laws which diverge from UK laws
and in doing so would separate our own
country from the rest United Kingdom
We're British
and we expect to be governed by British
law not Brussels law and we've certainly
not collaborate in administering
Brussels law in our part of the United
Kingdom
you say you would be obliged by law to
carry out the agreement but you would
refuse to do that so in other words you
would break the law
no we wouldn't we would simply refuse to
participate in the assembly and of
course under the Good Friday agreement
because we are we do live in a debated
Society the assembly can only operate if
there is a consent of both unions and
nationalists to a top relation and to
what goes on now and if our consent is
to be
not given to the uh the laws which were
required to administer then the assembly
can't operate that's as simple as that
and you know I think Ian Duncan Smith
yesterday made a very very good point
the government has a choice as it can
protect the Good Friday agreement or
dispense with it in order to comply with
the demands of of Brussels and the EU I
think that the UK government has uh
stream it to first of all protect peace
in Northern Ireland protect the union
not the European Union the union of the
United Kingdom and that's what the
outcome of these negotiations must be
otherwise you know that's unreasonable
to ask your nurse to participate in an
arrangement which is designed for the
breakup of the Union
and that's what's at stake here and
that's why this is a historic moment for
the Prime Minister he's going to choose
as he the prime minister of the whole of
the United Kingdom or is he the prime
minister of part of the United Kingdom
who's prepared to abandon another part
to the demands of the Europe the
European Union
uh would he make of suggestions over the
weekend that the Prime Minister before
last Boris Johnson has been tinkering
around
well first of all
um what he Boris Johnson has said is
that it makes sense in negotiations to
have as much leverage as you have if you
can and one of the ways of achieving
that is for the government to see the
Northern Ireland protocol bill which
would in effect give the government uh
in in Westminster the right to act
unilaterally if they can't reach
agreement with the European Union his
argument has been that you've got far
more leverage if you've got an
alternative to uh the outcome of the
negotiations that's something actually
we have been arguing for since the
protocol bill was introduced and if the
former prime minister is now saying that
he believes that's a good tactic as well
then we welcome that and I hope that the
government does listen to that because
our fear is that they've gone into these
negotiations with an attitude of defeat
almost they have not seen the protocol
Bill through the House of Lords they
have already taken uh pars from the
storment government to uh Implement uh
border control potion build border
control posts of three ports in Northern
Ireland again the Tran please EU and
they've agreed that the Handover
commercial and trading data to the EU
something which EU had been demanding
all ahead of reaching any agreement and
you know it does cause you to wonder
sometimes about your negotiating tactics
why do you give the other side all of
the things they wanted for before they
give you anything in negotiations
just before I let you go Mr Wilson I'm
not sure if you are a betting man or not
maybe
um on the Gold Cup I'm not sure but if
you if you were a betting man um do you
think there'll be a deal over the line
this week
no I don't and I think that the Prime
Minister probably has done big things at
the weekend as well because he realizes
there there are barriers and Hills
Decline and um he knows the kind of
issues that have to be dealt with I hope
that he does join the negotiations with
a full understanding of what is required
we have got seven tests but don't forget
our seven tests are no different than
what the Prime Minister has promised he
wants to seek as well because in the
protocol Bill and in the command paper
which the government published last
bottom uh to deal with the protocol they
were asking for exactly the same things
as I've been talking about here this
morning so
um he knows the Gap that exists at
present
and I hope that he intends to keep on
group negotiations until that cap was
closed
good to talk to you thanks for taking
the time much appreciated thank you
thank you
um tomorrow's with us this morning's
Mario thoughts good morning
is the government going to finally get
that last piece of the brexit puzzle
sorting out the trade Arrangements in
Northern Ireland well clear that Sammy
Wilson from the Democratic unionist
party doesn't think a deal can be done
this week despite what she's seen at
going to Northern Ireland on Friday
speaking to EU leaders over the weekend
I think Downing Street are a bit more
optimistic it looks like all the
momentum is that a deal could be done
this week although I'm told it won't be
today but the unionists have set a very
high bar with these seven tests and the
particularly difficult one as we were
hearing there is about who oversees
these Arrangements is it going to be the
European court of justice which would be
a red line for the dup or can some way
around that be found that is what the
negotiations have focused on for months
and months now but whether there can be
a compromise everyone can agree to it
looks like the momentum is going in that
direction but there is still some way to
go in those talks and the suggestion
today that Downing Street may put a deal
to MPS here in Parliament without the
dup's approval is not been shot down
today by sources in number 10.
okay tomorrow thank you still to come on
the program for you this morning does
Lancashire police deserve to be
criticized over their handling of the
Nicola bully case so far find out what
one former Chief Constable has to say
about that
[Music]
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show we are in Lancashire
again this morning our top story
police are expected to complete their
identification of a body found in the
river wire around a mile from where
Nicola bully disappeared three weeks ago
more than 11 000 ambulance workers
across England and Wales are walking out
again today in a row overpay and
Staffing
and the dup's Samuelson has accused the
government of going to talks with the EU
with an attitude of defeat and predicts
that no deal will be agreed this week on
post-brexit trading agreements for
Northern Ireland
I'm going to tell you more about the
family family forgive me of Nicola bully
out there waiting for police to formally
identify a body discovered yesterday
around a mile from where she disappeared
her partner Paul anselors told Sky News
he has no words right now just agony
Lancashire police is also facing growing
questions over its investigation uh
joined now by the former Chief Constable
of Greater Manchester police and
neighboring force of course uh sir Peter
pahi hello to you sir Peter thank you
for joining us
criticism of Lancashire police over the
last three weeks is any of it valid
um I'm not sure it is you know and you
are seeing quite a number of people
um you know a police expertise retired
officers coming out raising concerns
about some of that criticism that it
seems to me that they did very Vigilant
inquiries around the local CCTV
um they had great support from local
people and from that we're able to trace
all the local witnesses that have seen
Nicola and fellow dog walkers and they
also did extensive mobile phone tracing
that actually meant they were able to
narrow down the circumstances in which
it appeared that Nicola had disappeared
um but then the trouble with that is
that they then didn't have a lot more
information to give to the press in
terms of further leads or further
inquiries perhaps vehicles or people
they needed to trace because they had
been able to narrow things down in this
particular way
um so you know I think a lot of the
criticism has not been Justified and
it's really not in the public interest
when officers apply to investigate the
case like this but every detail is
poured over
um you know we've had all the influence
of social media people coming into the
area in the end the police said get
dispersal order to remove some of those
people so I think the police have been
under huge pressure but from everything
I see you know they've tried to carry
out those inquiries in the methodical
way but they're with a quite
extraordinary level of press and public
interest which to some degree is
understandable but on the other hand
will be enormously frustrating to many
many other families who've lost loved
ones so saying why do we not get this
level of coverage and interest
so Peter the police have always said
right from the first news conference
that they thought that she was in the
water they continue to say throughout
that as far as they were concerned their
working hypothesis was that she was in
the water in other words that she was no
longer with us why on Earth did they
release information about her struggling
with the menopause and having a problem
with alcohol when they thought that she
was no longer with us
well so you know that's something that
they will have to justify I would point
out that you know whoever sadly this
body turns out to be there will be an
inquest in quest heard in public uh and
often an inquest uh extreme you know
huge amounts of personal detail uh are
released about a person's personal and
medical mental health then you know
background
um you know at the end of the day
Relationship police are accountable to
the police and crime commissioner
elected by the people of Lancashire
um and and they will be held to account
by that person but I think the fact is
they run to huge pressure
um you know and yes you can question
whether that was right or not but as I
say I would point out in many many
inquiries investigations many personal
details have to be released uh they
feature in the criminal trial if there
is an idiot trial and certainly an
inquest because all those are public
hearings
yeah but if it was important information
why didn't they release it initially
I don't know you know that that's for
them you know the trouble you know they
face is not really for them I'm asking
you
sister Peter no I'm asking you and you
are defending the actions of a
neighboring force and I understand why
you're doing that and I'm just putting
to you that This Woman's reputation has
been trashed and the police thought that
she was already dead
no I don't think you know that yes they
believe that the most likely outcome was
that she was already dead because of all
the inquiries that they had made
um and they felt it was in in the
interest and the public interest
interesting investigation to release
that information I don't know it was
right or wrong I you know was not there
in the investigation as I say there's a
very strong system of accountability
that they will have to be answerable too
and the ultimate judge of this really is
the family of of Port Nicola and the
police doing everything that they can to
try and obviously get some form of
resolution to them but overall I think
the level of criticism has been
completely you know unjustified and
unbalanced at least a lot of officers
feeling uh disillusioned and as I say
there's a wider issue here about when
officers are under this degree of press
interest but public but particularly all
the issues on social media which I know
are very difficult to counter it just
makes that investigation much more
difficult and yes that will have to be
reflected upon by officers and by
Lancashire police as to whether there's
anything that they could have done
differently
the reason that there's been so much
interest is that it was a young mum of
two who went for a walk with her little
dog she disappeared at a Beauty Spot and
she was missing for three weeks we were
told that the river had been searched
and searched and searched again a body's
been found less than a mile away from
where she entered the water according to
the police
yeah and anybody that knows anything
about rivers and tidal flows and how
bodies behave when they enter a water
um you know we'll know this is extremely
complex and difficult in trying to you
know search that you know I come back to
it you know everything I see is the
police so the Lancashire police have
been very Vigilant in all their
inquiries they've had great local
support
um you know I've never seen a case which
is at that degree of uh of Interest yes
there was some element of it being a
sort of like a mystery people say well
she disappeared off the face of the
earth I think Lancashire police from an
early stage looking at all the different
information they had had this particular
hypothesis they always stressed that
they were trying to keep an open mind
but the difficulty they had was there
was this degree of public interest press
interest and at the end of the day they
didn't really have a lot more to say
um sadly they had to wait you know for
for the search and and for the body to
to be found
um and as but as I say that has been
frustrating then for the press and and
and for the public
and you don't so you don't feel from
what you're saying that criticisms by
the Home Secretary and also by the Prime
Minister who says that this Force has
questions to answer are valid
you know well I think you know they've
expressed concerns I don't think they've
criticized the police and I think the
fact is they don't know all the details
of the investigation it is highly
unusual for National politicians to
intervene in a case like this as I say
the person the police are accountable at
the local level is the police and crime
commissioner and I'm sure their office
will look into this very closely
um but again you know on the other hand
I think there will be lots of other
families out there today who'll say Well
Mr Prime Minister can you please show
the same level of interest in in my case
because sadly every day there are
hundreds of people who go missing many
many are found by the police but there
are many families out there who sadly
are going through the agony every single
day
you say the
um Home Secretary wasn't critical she
said she was concerned and she wanted
answers
yes it was fine you know and she said
and I'm sure Lancashire police will
express it will give those answers but
I'd still say it is very unusual for a
Home Secretary to get involved in a live
police investigation okay because of the
level of press and public interest you
felt she had to do that I'm just
pointing out that there is a very strong
accountability mechanism for the police
through the elected peace and crime
commissioner as well as a whole body of
expertise that the police follow they
will look at this case they would review
they cut this case they will see what
learning that would be passed on to
other detectives around the country
because I say the police build all this
on huge amount of experience and
expertise all the officers involved have
had to be highly trained and accredited
uh and you know everything I've seen as
I've tried to do their best in this very
difficult case
thank you for joining us so Peter always
much appreciated thank you
um Industries here been listening to
what Peter had to say interesting
because very very defensive you know as
a former Chief Constable probably would
be of a force you know Lancashire police
is a big big Force One of the one of the
largest in the country it's got to cover
a huge ground as well and yes there has
been a massive amount of criticism uh as
to how they've carried out this
investigation I think in some instances
as well it's really overshadowed the
core uh you know mission of this
investigation that is to find Nicola
bully and you know for a family who just
want Nicola home you know they've had to
deal with also the Fallout of Lancashire
police's uh way that they've carried out
this investigation and the fact that
it's reached very senior levels of
government as well the Home Secretary
and Rishi sunak so yes of course it's of
Peter farhi you know someone who has
been Chief constable Cheshire police
great Manchester police will of course
be incredibly defensive of it but I
think it would be down to reviews a
number of reviews internal from
Lancashire the independent office for
police conduct and the information
commissioner and of course the Home
Secretary
um to have get some of those answers and
see exactly how well they've they've
done in this investigation just a quick
thought he was critical of the public
interest in this case why do you think
there has been such a wide public
interest let's just quickly paint that
picture again Kay you know a mum of two
a 45 year old went missing
she's got two daughters at home a phone
was left on a bench unlocked a dog was
left on its own scoring between the
bench and a gate and it's its harness on
the floor all next to a river a cold and
in some parts a Deep River it's such a
vivid image
that what on Earth has happened here you
know it's an absolute mystery and I
think in this day and age in social
media
Tick Tock people have taken to those
platforms to try and figure out
themselves what's gone on but there are
things at the very heart of it the fact
that she is a mom the fact that she owns
a dog and the fact that it is a huge
mystery and so so many people just want
to try and find out what happened to
Nicola bully and of course let's not
forget that the police were appealing
for anybody who had any information
including Dash coming from 700 vehicles
that pass the road just here
um to get in touch um for now insi
thanks very much indeed of course we'll
have more on this story The Family at
home this morning waiting to hear the
news whether the body that was found
less than a mile away from where Nicola
disappeared just over three weeks ago is
that of their beloved daughter mum
sister partner
looking at some of today's other
headlines in the meantime 70 MPS from
all parties have signed an open letter
to the government calling for more
support for Ukrainian refugees in the UK
to prevent them from becoming homeless
it comes as new data shows more than 4
000 Ukrainian households have needed
help from councils in the past year
after becoming homeless
from Tottenham Hotspur I have called on
social media companies to intervene
following racist abuse directed against
forward son hyung-min the South Korean
Captain scored's first second goal
during Sunday's two nil win over West
Ham the club has described the abuse as
utterly reprehensible
the NHS is being hit by a further round
of strikes today with ambulance staff
walking out in the ongoing dispute
overpay and Staffing let's get more on
that now with gmb's national secretary
Andy Prendergast Prendergast hello to Mr
Prendergast thanks for joining us on the
program this morning just remind us
where we are on your pay demands
well okay I mean we've asked for a
substantial increase
um we think that's a fair claim uh it's
one that ultimately I think most of the
public support and they see that there's
a clear rationale for it sadly the
government aren't listening so we're
having to have yet another day of strike
action
uh the government said that's over we're
not negotiating any further on that but
we're happy to talk to you about next
year's pay deal and that negotiation
starts soon anyway
well to be honest with UK there's not
actually a negotiation I mean a
government hide behind the so-called
independent pay review body which we've
long had an issue with it's not
independent and quite frankly it's
failed in its task uh there's Mass
vacancies across the service the public
aren't getting the the service that they
they pay for and the conditions our
members work in are appalling and until
pay is addressed these aren't going to
get any better
we're here
um and we've heard from several
government ministers who've suggested
that you're putting patients lives at
risk by going on strike
well we hear this all the time and
frankly if people are putting patients
lives at risk it's the government by
refusing to talk to us as we sit here at
the moment we haven't had any meaningful
discussions with them for the last month
there's none in the diary what we're
seeing across the NHS is more and more
unions every day are bringing out more
and more members there's an absolute
crisis hitting the service and frankly
the government's response has been to
put his head in the sand they need to
understand that this isn't going
anywhere that public support remains
strong and ultimately the people want to
see a decent pay rise for the pandemic
Heroes who got us through that terrible
time
uh the nurses um also
um I have had several strikes already
continuing with that including a 48-hour
strike and previously it had been 12
hours strikes are you planning on
ratcheting up strike action if you get
no further discussions
um well at the moment we've got two
further days of strike action planned
after today uh we'll continue to talk to
our reps and our members about what they
want to after that but what it would say
is the temperature running High
um you know unfortunately we're in a
situation where we're getting lots of
stories about the derogations that have
been agreed for critical injuries and
critical care are being abused by local
managers I think our members are seeing
government who are refusing to talk who
are refusing to listen and what the
government need to understand is this
isn't going to go away they need to come
to the table they need to talk to us
meaningfully I mean you mentioned about
next year's pay talks they still haven't
put their evidence into the pay review
process
um it seems that quite frankly they're
asleep at a wheel
thank you very much indeed for joining
us this morning thank you thank you
the U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken is in Ankara where he's spoken
about turkey's support for Ukraine this
Friday marks one year of the war in
Ukraine as the anniversary approaches
the US has warned China of consequences
if it sends weapons and ammunition to
help Russia's invasion of Ukraine for
more on this and a look back at the year
joined by the former U.S national
security adviser and former ambassador
to the UN that's John Bolton always a
pleasure Mr Bolton thank you for joining
us before we start
um did I hear that you've thrown or
about to throw your hat in the ring to
be the next president of the United
States
well I'm thinking about it I looked at
it very seriously in 2016 and decided
not to but I was very concerned about
the Donald Trump's comments some weeks
back that the U.S Constitution should be
terminated so that he could be declared
the winner of the 2020 election and I
wasn't satisfied with the response of
the people who are considering running
so I thought I ought to be serious about
it because I think it's important to end
this idea that the 2020 election was
stolen or that Donald Trump really has
any claim on the Loyalty of
conservatives or Republicans
if you run do you think you'll win
well I wouldn't run unless I thought I
could win I wouldn't do this simply to
make the point it's a very arduous
process as I think people know so it
requires some due diligence before
making the decision and and that's
really what I'm in the process of doing
now
when will you decide
well I think in the next few months the
process is a little bit slower than I
anticipated it would be there are a lot
of people who are looking at getting in
and one thing I think we all want to
avoid is to have so many people in the
race that Trump is able to slip between
them and get the nomination I don't
think he will be the nominee ultimately
anyway and I don't think he would win if
God forbid he did become the Republican
nominee
let's talk about China two things what
are they up to when it comes to
supporting Russia against Ukraine and of
course these spy balloons as well choose
which one you want to First
well in terms of support for Russia uh I
know secretary blanken uh warned them
about supplying weapons honestly for the
past year China has been giving Russia
enormous support already there's no
doubt in my mind that sanctioned Russian
financial institutions are laundering
money through China's extraordinarily
opaque Financial system and China has
substantially increased its purchases of
Russian oil and natural gas to make up
for revenues lost in other sales I don't
doubt that in more clandestine ways
China's also been helping Russia perhaps
assisting North Korea in its sales of
artillery and ammunition and in many
other ways the idea that somehow China
and Russia have split over the invasion
of Ukraine has always been wrong it's
really quite the opposite they're
forming a closer and closer on time and
it it's a problem for the West as a
whole going forward the the Chinese
balloon which I think was very badly
missed handled by the Biden
Administration is significant in its own
right the people theorize that one
reason they're interested in balloon
surveillance over the United States is
that in the event of War people have
spoken for a long time about China's
anti-satellite program being designed to
take out American eyes in the sky so
they would expect we would then do the
same to theirs and balloon surveillance
is a substitute a poor substitute I
think but something to look at so this
this should be this balloon should be a
wake-up call for people in the United
States and Europe and elsewhere who
don't think China is a threat in the
21st century in in my view China is the
existential threat in the 21st century
but I thought China had all these sort
of technology in space where they could
read number plates from the moon or
whatever why do they need to have these
balloons around
right well their their cameras may not
be as good as ours but but even if they
are as I say in a circumstance in
conflict or in pre-conflict crisis when
the sides were destroying their
satellite observation capabilities
having some alternative high-flying
aircraft like the U2 that we have or or
these balloons could be at least
something of a substitute and Chinese
research may be moving faster ahead on
that than ours has been but to be sure
this is a serious matter but it's
indicative of the extraordinarily
widespread nature of Chinese
surveillance efforts against the United
States and and the West as a whole
with some President Biden right to say
shoot him down
but frankly he should have he should
have shot it down before it crossed over
into Alaska according to press reports
we had actually been tracking that
balloon since it left the island of Hana
and south of the Chinese Mainland about
a week before it showed up over the
Aleutian Islands I think the presumption
should be an unidentified aircraft that
we have no idea what the payload is or
what its capabilities are get shot down
before it endangers Americans
and you think that there was similar
incidents during the Trump
Administration
well we we were certainly I was
certainly not notified of it the I have
had a uh uh highly classified briefing
by the office of the Director of
National Intelligence for which I thank
the administration so I'm somewhat
constrained in what I can say but I
think I think it's clear that there have
been a lot of unidentified phenomena in
past years that it's been observed but
uh but our analysts have not been able
to understand what it is I think this
balloon and the research that's been
done in the past couple of years
indicates that there's probably a lot
more of this than we knew in the past so
we we learned from that we increased the
capacity of our radar and other
detection systems and uh just to try and
make our perimeter more secure than it
has been
and just go back to your comments about
Russia and China you feel that uh China
is already supplying uh lethal Weaponry
to Russia in the war against Ukraine
well it wouldn't be surprising or you
know non-governmental organizations in
China volunteering their assistance to
the Russians I wouldn't take anything
either one of them says at face value
and the fact that the United States
government is only commenting on it now
doesn't mean that it's just started
right now China has a vested interest in
this on taunt with Russia the only
disagreement between the two countries
over the war in Ukraine I think is
probably Chinese disappointment that the
Russians aren't doing better
okay thank you very much indeed for
joining us as always Mr Bolton look
forward to seeing you in the studio
again soon thank you thank you just a
quick thought um Lindsay about what
we're expecting today up here in
Lancaster well look I think Lancashire
police will be working in the early
hours this morning as this Village wakes
up to try and get the information uh to
identify uh the body that they retrieve
from the water yesterday if it is Nicola
bully I wouldn't be surprised if they
gather the media together to do a news
conference to deliver more information
that's of course things that we are
waiting to hear from Lancashire police
but this Village is waking up the school
will be opening up soon when Nicholas
two daughters would have gone and I
think very a lot of people will be
concerned hurt and in pain waking up in
this Village this morning that's
absolutely right Lindsay thanks very
much indeed um so if you are just tuning
our way we are up in Lancashire again
this morning morning after the news that
a body was discovered
in the river wire just before lunchtime
yesterday that body has not yet been
identified but we have heard from the
family who are completely numb this
morning waiting for the news as to
whether or not it is lovely